what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU prices are very high right now
and many of us would undoubtedly point
our fingers at cryptocurrency miners for
the rapid increase in GPU prices in the
last couple of months well guys as
gamers may be saved from this irrelevant
craze and here is why GPU mining isn't
actually diamond but miners litchi up
gaming GPUs is done this is because
Nvidia seems to be bringing out a mining
dedicated graphics card to keep miners
off the gaming oriented ones this GPU is
codenamed Turing after the famous
computer pioneer Alan Turing I'm not
going to be getting into the details
about tearing right now but if you're
interested in that then make sure to
check out my dedicated video but just as
a recap tearing is supposed to be a
really good mighty card as much superior
to gaming cards in terms of mining which
will hopefully drive most if not all
miners away from the gaming market so
where does that leave current graphics
cards and gamers
well Nvidia also has a gaming series
planned to launch alongside attorney
which is coded ampere
unfortunately NPR seems to just be a
Pascal refresh and not what we expected
as voltage but ampere also seems to
deliver a noticeably significant upgrade
and as a result it'll be pretty
reasonable the GTX 2060 is expected to
match the performance of the GTX 1080 to
give you some perspective on that on my
video about ampere I received some
questions about why miners wouldn't just
turn to gaming GPUs after their mining
graphics cards run out well here's my
take on it Nvidia is in a great position
right now in terms of sales from revenue
and that just seems to be going up
however there aren't very bad terms with
gamers themselves many gamers feel that
it is invidious fault for not handling
GPU mining properly and not pre-planning
for pen potential GPU shortages and as a
result in the video we'll want to regain
a trust of gamers by redeeming
themselves at the same time they don't
want to lose mining consumers and that's
precisely why they're launching too
lines thus I personally believe that in
video would designed the gaming chips in
a way that it does not excel in mining
like it wouldn't have good hash rates
and things of that sort
Nvidia will probably do something like
this but I really doubt they want to
receive a lot of backlash from there I
guess permanent consumers - much more
volatility in video than gamers so
anybody would want to keep their gaming
consumers NVIDIA has already stopped the
production of some parts that are used
in their 10 series GPUs so this next
year is right around the corner and peer
and Turing expected to be revealed on
March 26th at GDC and released on April
12 so what is the main point I wanted to
get across in this video well all I
wanted to tell you guys is that from now
on GPU cryptocurrency mining should not
affect gamers anymore due to some
upcoming graphics cards from Nvidia well
guys that's all I have for you guys on
this video but make sure to continue
this discussion down in the comments
down below
I read all my comments and I am curious
as to what you guys are thinking for
example what do you think miners being
pulled away from the gaming scene will
do and what do you think ampere and
cheering will do - GPU prices will they
skyrocket themselves or will they be
more forgiving also if you have any
constructive criticism that makes your
comment dad as well because I would like
to improve my videos to make them more
enjoyable and/or informative for you
guys but that's what I have for you guys
it's time you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like on this video and
smash that subscribe button if you guys
loved it and we would like to see more
videos just like this but until next
time bye